[Musique]
les élus du département présente
publiquement le projet de la route des
eaux de l'est 40 km de routes
départementales situées à mi hauteur
permettront de relier saint benoît saint
denis les grands enjeux de cette route
c'est d'abord de fluidifier la
circulation
diminuer le taux d'embouteillages qui
existe entre l'est et le nord c'est de
renforcer les connexions entre les
bourdes et mi pente et des eaux entre
les différents villages entre
saint-andré et sept maris
c'est aussi développer les terrains
agricoles puisqu'il n'y a plus de 4500
hectares qui sont concernés par une
reconquête des friches ses conséquences
que cette zone nord-est s'est développé
le tourisme que nous ayons notre route
balcon au même titre que la route hubert
delisle s'est développé l'économie en
ayant des unités aussi économique des
entreprises qui s'installent sur les mi
pente c'est d'apporter un souffle
nouveau au territoire est rééquilibré le
territoire le temps de l'est est venu
parce que les autres territoires sont
saturés aujourd'hui ils étaient nombreux
à avoir fait le déplacement pour cette
réunion publique de présentation
trois tracés de route sont actuellement
à l'étude la population pourra se
prononcer et donner son avis sur le site
rh et pour un département 9 7 4 points
fr aujourd'hui on propose trois
variantes qui sont soumises à la
concertation du public pour que chacun
puisse s'exprimer
et le résultat de cette concertation
permettra d'affiner
un tracé définitif qui sera simplement
la résultante est très certainement la
combinaison de ces trois tracés
communique pas reconnu de manière
inévitable quand on est un tracé
évidemment cohérent d'un billet jusqu'à
l'autre mais contiennent ainsi compte de
toutes les attentes de la population
les premiers travaux devraient démarrer
en 2021 la route des eaux de l'est
permettra en principe de gagner environ
30 minutes sur le trajet saint benoît
saint denis aux heures de pointe
[Musique]